[Music]
if you're new to this channel one of the
things we like to do around here is do
creative experiments everything from
build a net gun to build a potato camera
to heck we even made a seven foot
electric skateboard no one on the
internet has built a full-sized fully
functional guillotine we knew we had to
do it not only did this seem like a
creative challenge but also one of
historical significance and in addition
on friday evenings we like to go down
and get a couple of beers we figured if
this guillotine can make enough money to
earn 50 bucks a month it'll be able to
pay for those beers i need to
deconstruct part of the studio in order
for me to get this guillotine build done
today
so like anything good work takes time
and six months later here we are all
that's left to build is the blade and
the slide
i told you guys we weren't as close as i
thought we were and it turns out that
that was true i am not a carpenter i'm a
fan of carpentry
dude i didn't really know the function
of a router so all you commenters thank
you for for slapping yourself on the
heads and typing in router jake router i
got a router i went back i bought two
more of these four by fours and i redid
this whole map oh man all that all that
all that work and basically i rerouted
this which allowed me to then put in
these aluminum triangles it's gonna be a
slide it's gonna have a detachable blade
on it my ultimate goal here is to create
a prototype that will slide all the way
down the guillotine without falling out
or being janky or anything once we have
a functioning slide i'll feel confident
enough to take this whole design to a
machinist so that they can make
something out of metal i don't want to
do any experimentation with machinists
because that could get expensive really
fast this is going to be loud when it
hits
i dedicate this guillotine
big chungus
[Music]
palace well the rest of the people of
france are starving finish it shake
finish it it's easy to understand how
carried away the french got when we're
already getting super excited like
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
now that we know that it works we're
going to go to the machinist we're going
to have them make a functioning blade
and slide based upon this prototype
all right we made it we're here at eric
machinery custom machine work since 1924
we're going to go in see about getting
this blade made
without all sorts of things but not in
the lady
i've got some dimensions for it we can
put up lavender i do want the blade to
be pretty big so i think a half an inch
you gotta love places like this with all
the different machines they have in here
the ability to just go i can make
anything i want yeah my dad had this
exact table saw
[Music]
so while the blade is being manufactured
we're going to paint the whole
guillotine white might change later but
for now this is going to be a great base
coat and give us a starting point today
is a very special day in the life of
this guillotine just as with a newborn
child the baptism is a beautiful moment
in its life today is the day that we get
a real frenchman to hopefully give his
blessings on our guillotine they say
that all guillotines must be approved by
an official frenchman
how do you say it again
there's been a lot of debate how do we
say the word guillotine guillotines
guillotine guillotine guillotines
guillotine doesn't really matter how i
say it everyone in the comments everyone
in the studio there is no debate it's
pronounced guile time
guess what everybody we're gonna settle
this once and for all to figure out how
you say the name of this here device
after that i don't want to see a single
comment i've got five dollars american
on guillotine well i'll bet you five
that it's guillotine i got five on it
i bet five dollars that is pronounced
gal time all right
now i'm good man
we're making a whole channel well i was
gonna say it oh
[Music]
i'm helping
henry if you would please come forward
and and slowly with confidence of all
your ancestors place your hands on the
guillotine
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh my god
[Applause]
i was obviously the closest so you guys
actually owed me i don't believe any of
this i get five dollars he pronounced it
differently no a guillotine is not a
real guillotine without a frenchman's
blessing
[Music]
[Music]
now that that guillotine has been
blessed i wanted to bless you guys with
a little secret people ask us all the
time what kind of music we use in our
videos and including this video and this
last scene you just saw we get our music
from today's sponsor epidemic if you
post videos online epidemic is a great
way to get a bunch of music for those
videos they have over 30 000 tracks that
are updated weekly they also have
editorial selections if you guys don't
have time to go through 30 000 tracks
now with a creator subscription to
epidemic you are whitelisted across
youtube facebook twitch instagram and if
you choose to end your subscription at
any time all the content that you made
during that period on those platforms is
100 good to go it'll never be touched
all the tracks that you get from
epidemic come with stems so if you just
like the baseline
or you just want the violin from one
piece you can pull the stems put it in
your video and adjust it and make it as
you see fit a creator subscription is
only 15 bucks a month what the music you
heard in the last scene the music you're
hearing right now it can be yours just
click the link in the description two
months free that's it now you guys know
you don't need to ask us any more in the
comments all right i'm going to get back
to it
it's just steel sheet metal coldly
machined and sharpened and it's the most
magnificent thing i've seen since the
birth of my children the problem is that
i thought it was going to be 30 pounds
it's 50. the slight building flaw that
was inherent to the 4x4s that i was
using is now causing a problem this mast
100 straight this one has a slight warp
to it see it bows out slightly that
means that even though at the top and
bottom it's 17 and 3 8 inches
in the center it's just slightly wider
and a slight variation when you're
dealing with a sharpened piece of steel
that can chop a horse's head off is way
too dangerous i need to make this thing
safe before we use it i can't wait to
taste that beer dude i can't believe we
did all this for beer the first day that
we go out and use an adsense check to
buy a bunch of beer for this is gonna be
that's just gonna be such a good day son
it's gonna taste so good
oh you got it dude just touch him dude
just touch him this has so much force
it's like a train it's just gonna plow
through stuff
this is it look at it's on wheels in
order to fix the boeing problem i used
two two by fours with carriage bolts to
bring the entire mast slightly closer
together this will prevent the blade
from having any chance of sliding out as
for the stopping mechanism i got this
rubber right here you guys can go ahead
and please actually leave me comments in
terms of what you think would be a
better stopping mechanism and i
understand that it's not the best thing
to stop all the force of the blade and
slide by where the blade impacts but i
want to try
this first it's just super super hard
rubber
this is like a giant
200 pound slab of rubber oh my gosh
where did you get that where did you get
that oh mother mother humper oh my
god oh my god i think i just threw up my
back just lifting that brush and i'm
just gonna cut a chunk out of it and
just put it on the bottom one hour later
dude look at this i don't know how it
was even caught in the first place i i
have no idea where this material like
came from mars how am i supposed to cut
all the way down this i need this to
work this was my what this was my
solution this has to work desperate
times call for desperate measures
this is so sketchy
[Applause]
how to cut rubber
box cutter a tire cutter half or knife
there's no way to do this
dude this is the worst
how did how did we come to this
how did we get here
i'm making
this is the perfect time to do it if we
can make 50 bucks a month on a
guillotine channel that's our goal
that's our goal that will pay for the
beer for the beer for the beer the beer
the beer the beer the beer the beer the
beer the beer the beer
whoa
that was one of the most unpleasant
things i've ever cut through and i've
cut through a lot of unpleasant things
crowds at disneyland
l.a traffic
[Music]
ready yep ready
[Music]
ah i knew the rubber i look at it barely
made a dent i knew the rubber was a good
idea
i think we can go
we can go big
[Music]
like we might need a couple guys on the
team since we don't have a winch
i need everyone paying attention for
this this is like firing off a firearm
and i have no idea what's gonna happen
anything that's beneath that blade is
going to completely explode we're going
to find pieces up in the kitchen all
right guys all right
oh
a guillotine has dropped in america in
hundreds of years
oh that's perfect yeah it doesn't bounce
too much you know how your camera shook
there yeah you know what that means the
concrete ground flexed a little bit
we felt that next door really yeah
shake that
concrete now that it's like functioning
and i and i have it all working now we
can like add a bench in the front we can
add a winch on the side i think we're
ready to chop i think we're ready to
start this channel
loose
all right ready three two one dropper oh
you thought it was gonna chop you
thought we were gonna put the guillotine
videos on this channel no there's a
channel called youtube.com guillotine
channel subscribe for pure unadulterated
guillotine related content
hello and welcome back to the guillotine
channel your source for family friendly
guillotine content don't you hate how
you used to have to watch a whole
documentary on the french revolution
just just to see one good guillotine
shot